Donald Trump over the weekend has done something
that was inconceivable for a president to
do before Donald Trump.
But now that every day is a scandal, it doesn't
even get the attention that it deserves.
Everything has changed.
And in a completely incoherent way that only
Donald Trump can do things.
Donald Trump started to foment rebellion on
Twitter and at his press briefings against
the public health measures to slow the spread
of Corona virus, supporting the completely
dangerous and ignorant protests of the infowars
types of the Don't Tread on Me types of the
Magga people who are mass gathering without
masks, without social distancing to demand
that their states reopen in the midst of the
current Corona virus pandemic, as many of
these states are seeing rapidly on a percentage
basis, rapidly increasing cases.
Donald Trump tweeting over the weekend as
the protests mount, quote, liberate Minnesota,
liberate Michigan, liberate Virginia and save
your great Second Amendment.
It is under siege.
Few things can make people turn to violence
like a Republican president telling his followers
that their gun rights are under siege.
Then Trump defending the protesters during
his press briefings, despite their completely
irresponsible lack of social distancing and
masks.
Trump defending them, saying, hey, listen,
some of these restrictions are.
Tough.
Well, I think we do have a sobering guidance,
but I think some things are too tough.
And if you look at some of the states you
just mentioned that it's too tough.
Not only relative to this, but what they've
done in Virginia with respect to the Second
Amendment is just a horrible thing.
They did a horrible thing.
The governor and he's a governor under a cloud
to start off with.
So when you see what he said about the Second
Amendment, when you see what other states
have done.
No, I think I feel very comfortable to be
clear when you talk about these states, Michigan,
Minnesota, Virginia, do you think deficient
lived their stay at home owners or can you
talk about the elements of what they've done
is too much and it's just too much?
You know the elements because I've already
said sure.
Are you concerned, though, that people coming
out in protest are going to spread to other
people there congregating in ways that health
experts have said they should not?
You know, these are people expressing their
views.
I see where they are.
I see the way they're working.
They seem to be very responsible people to
me.
But it's you know, they've been treated a
little bit differently.
There it is.
The protesters are being treated roughly.
The people in states are being treated roughly.
But the behavior of the protesters at mass
rallies when there are distancing guidelines
from the federal government.
That's all fine, apparently.
Now understand how incomprehensible this is.
First, Trump claimed to have absolute authority
over the states, which he doesn't have.
Eventually, somebody clearly got to Trump
and said, listen, you don't have the authority.
So Trump did a 180.
And in his plan to reopen, he said this is
all totally up to the governors, which is
true.
It is.
But now Trump is supporting rebellion against
the governors who Trump said he is confident
in to do the right thing.
This is much worse than merely egging on protesters
in a vacuum, which is bad enough.
Trump is actually encouraging people to violate
the guidelines, which he said at the federal
level and has asked states to follow.
He's encouraging risky behavior from a public
health perspective.
It's going to lead to more infections and
deaths.
It's just a matter of math.
This language of liberating states.
He's using language which can only serve to
encourage horrible behavior.
And then Trump's tweets equally erratic throughout
the weekend, including a bunch of tweets going
after states about them having to do more,
more testing, which is hilarious because all
along Trump's argument has been testing is
perfect and it's because of him.
Now, when it becomes undeniable that we simply
don't have enough testing to reopen and we'll
talk about that more tomorrow.
Trump starts sending tweets out about how.
Listen.
These state governors really have to get testing
figured out.
And then around the same time, as he sent
those Liberacion tweets, he included attacks
on the World Health Organization.
Another scapegoat now for his terrible leadership,
as well as going after Democrats like Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer, claiming they're
on vacation, when, of course, they're no more
on vacation than you know.
Congressman Dan Crenshaw and every Republican
and Democrat in the House and Senate, all
of whom are simply in their districts right
now during the quarantine rather than in Washington,
D.C..
So this was never funny.
It was it was always horrifying.
But now it's extra not funny as it becomes
more and more dangerous and there will be
more death as a result of this.
And unfortunately, it's increasingly looking
like there will be violence as a result of
this at some point as well.
If it hasn't started already and we will soon
hear about it.
Follow us on Instagram for continued coverage
of all of these whacked out protests.
We are at Davidge Tatem Show
on Instagram.